now let's everybody keep cool in good
shape if we need to get home but all the
problem but let's not make it any worse
bike yeah this is part of the famous
exchange between NASA flight director
Gene Kranz and Apollo 13 astronauts in
1970 it helped immortalize NASA's
Mission Control Center in Houston the
once bustling building was the epicenter
of several milestones in human history
they include Man's first steps on the
moon but today that room is retired and
erect mark Strassmann is inside the old
mission control room in Houston with the
efforts to bring the past back to life
mark good morning good morning this is
the mission control room where a
generation of Americans watched NASA
beat the Soviets in the race to the moon
for almost 30 years the people in this
room directed more than 40 Gemini Apollo
and space shuttle launches and landings
now there's a new mission here to save
this room why 20th 1969 man was on the
moon the world breathed a sigh of relief
and celebrated maybe no group moreso
than the people inside the Apollo
mission control room this room inside
building 30 of the Johnson Space Center
this room is sacred to me Gene Kranz now
83 was NASA's flight director during the
Gemini and Apollo missions we won the
battle for space in this room and we
captured the high ground and we did not
surrender it during our to her it was
Krantz who was in charge when an
explosion aboard Apollo 13 nearly cost
the lives of its three astronauts
that high drama was featured in the
movie Apollo 13
I want this mark all the way back to
earth with time to spare
Kranz was played by actor Edie Harris
failure is not an option
NASA used this mission control room with
its monochrome computer monitors and
rotary dial telephones starting in 1965
it went dark in 1992 well into the
shuttle program since then the room has
been designated a national historic
landmark but you never know that from
the looks of it houston we have a
problem
decay from years of neglect and souvenir
seekers who walked off with pieces of
space history take a look at the
consoles I used to have an abort switch
in there where the heck's the abort
switch the displace don't work anymore
when you look at the condition of the
room today what goes through your mind
it's a combination of frustration anger
resentment this is not appropriate this
is where our generation made history
this is where Apollo fulfilled the
challenge issued by President Kennedy is
the condition of this room an insult to
everybody in that period to make history
yes yes it is with NASA's slashed budget
the agency's priority is the future of
space travel not preserving its past
Space Center Houston the nonprofit that
runs the visitors center here has
launched a five million dollar
fundraising campaign to restore this
room to its 1960s glory it's not only
important for United States history but
world history William Harris Space
Center Houston CEO detail for us how
this iconic part of NASA's past will
have a brighter future all the council's
had to be removed restored buttons
replaced the screens will be redone all
of this is really old our commitment is
to restore it back to the way it was
Krantz wants to experience one more
thrill in this room to see it restored
and he's bringing his legendary can-do
spirit to the project this is a room
that will now represent the best America
had to offer failure is not an option
not an option but there is a deadline
fundraisers have until late summer to
come up with a needed five million
dollars in time to finish all these
needed repairs before the 50th
anniversary of Apollo 11s moon-landing
in july 2019 margaret mark do you hear
those guys reminds me of what Hemingway
once said courage is grace under
pressure these guys seem to have it and
it's remarkable that this I think most
Americans when they see this story will
want to contribute or help in some way
because it really is part of our
absolutely successful part of our
history mm-hmm amazing well thanks for
that story mark